have you seen that scene in have you
seen a movie fury with brad pitt have
you seen it where there's this one scene
where they go out
and he's in the tank
and they're getting shot up and one of
the soldiers cannot handle it he just
cannot handle it he's panicking he's
frozen he's locked up he doesn't know
what to do he starts peeing in his pants
and they have the scene it's a very good
scene to show that some people when it
hits you all of a sudden you don't know
how you're going to react your first
time and you know brad pitt's trying to
kind of calm the guy down and say hey
it's going to be all right go through it
was there ever a moment like that you
saw one of your peers that was tough
behind
you know enemy lines but then the moment
they crossed enemy lines that pressure
just kind of
exposed some of the fears that we may
have
not really i didn't experience that but
if you stopped and took notice
you could see
how some people didn't really fight to
stay in the front line units i guess
that's a better way and good for them i
mean if they knew beforehand that they
were in the wrong line of work or maybe
they were more uh suited to the
administrative side of the house or
something like that yeah um and they
went to places where they were less
likely to find themselves in iraq and
afghanistan i guess but that would be
the closest thing i can think of um just
because that training that we go through
is is so intense especially after people
started coming back from iraq and
afghanistan and incorporate those
lessons into the training um then for
sure it wasn't a surprise what you were
coming in to do uh so so i never really
experienced somebody having that type of
a
reaction downrange um but i'm sure i'm
sure it happened but i just never
experienced that yeah i if so for us we
we uh flew from l.a to uh atlanta and
then we got in the greyhound and then we
it was like five of us from l.a and we
drove to south carolina fort jackson and
we're driving everybody's tough because
everyone's from a gang and everyone's
you know this guy's from 18th street
that guy's from this this guy so we're
all bragging about who's tougher
and then you get to the unit and drill
sergeants come up and they start
hollering at you like okay i'm not used
to this you know what your girl is doing
right now she's with your best friend
hollering his name she ain't even
thinking about you right now she's
already over you know just mentally
messing with you yeah and then it got to
one of the tests
where you have to give the other guy ivs
okay and it's like it's not a big test i
mean to you probably iv is not a big
deal it's just you know you're just
putting an iv in your body so we're all
sitting there like a hundred of us
and one guy does the next guy does the
next guy does the five people refuse to
do it a couple of the guys do it they
knock out they pass that they can't
handle deal with needles uh uh it was
interesting seeing it you know as you're
going through the process
of how some of the things you were
prepared to go through some of the
things you were not prepared to go
through but again in your world it's a
completely different level you're a navy
seal you guys are seeing stuff that only
a few people get a chance to see so uh
out of curiosity for us we had a very uh
uh initiating type of an environment
where people were initiating new rookies
that were coming here
the hazing concept which was very normal
back in the days nowadays you know the
smallest joke you tell them you may get
the ets team not be dishonorably
discharged from the navy because you did
the wrong thing was the hazing thing
going on back then when you were in
because it was for us definitely
yeah no it was and uh you know i can see
how it could get out of hand at some
some levels or some places but
for me it was very positive experience i
mean i look back on those those times
with my new guys with our e5 mafia uh
all together there and going through
that that hazing and for whatever reason
the platoon that i was in as a new guy
they did a a great job with it and of
course the part you look forward to the
hazing you look forward to is getting
your trident and pounding that thing
into your chest uh that's the one you
look forward to you hear about it
happening to other people that's what
you want to have happen now it's
probably illegal now you go to jail if
you do it probably but uh
i mean that was like that's the right of
passage is your whole tune coming by and
what i remember is that the guys that
were huge that i thought were gonna hit
so hard yeah they didn't hit his heart
but like like the guys i thought were
gonna be like they hit so hard and uh i
distinctly remember that and they put
you up against the comics box there's no
give and they just bam bam pound that
thing and everybody cycles through in
the whole team and it was fantastic
today is there still a marvel today
no the pins are so small i mean once
they go in it's mostly uh
impact you know once you hit like
something because it is big you know
it is the trend is huge so it's just
those little pins are small they go in
and you know that's fine it's like in
your ears probably or something like
that especially when you're all yoked up
from doing thousands of push-ups and
pull-ups and buds so there's a little
little more padding back a little more
armor back then in the day so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye